putin’s troops are in ukraine and they are now bombing the Russian-speaking cities kiev kharkov here we have a few shots from there i’m zalyutino i want to show you me for putin i won’t even look at the photo this is nothing and there are no streets of the city shepherd to Kyiv well tell me about my position I am for Putin I am for Putin I about everything for him such no one bombs I don’t believe this Putin that they could attack Ukraine in that literally why attack if our residents live there I’m running around this Ukraine Belarus this happened why nothing I know to help there, saying something else, I bear why Putin sent troops specifically for the war, this is Delinsky all things and America day, I think that Putin is right, the moon knows what he is doing, therefore I don’t have a negative code for this doctor, so it’s necessary, and well, this is my opinion it means that we women can’t influence it all in any way, no matter how much you don’t like everything, don’t think that no matter how much we like it all, I understand that sanctions lead to server
it turns out that it will hit
our pockets, this is inflation, well, some kind of
unemployment, the same thing, well,
it means it’s necessary, so it’s here I
have my opinion there, which means we’ll have
to endure somehow I don’t want
to say it straight because we have as much as we
can for it  be some kind of danger,
it’s better to refrain from it I’m just for
peace and I don’t want everything you preemptive
strike column for life up to 1000 lives it’s
true it’s bitter it hurts what do you
want to do wait until we are
attacked the government of russia wants to
improve its
own
the actions of the lives of ordinary citizens, we have already been
sanctioned,
many countries
with which we cooperated could issue
that parent and continue to live, but
unfortunately this cannot be done
because of the way our president and the top
behave in a foreign country, why did he
put  500 people are already theirs, why don't
we know, well, [ __ ] him